[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv soixante dix
huit pour cette journée spéciale depuis
port marly pour l'université des mairies
le rendez-vous des collectivités locales
de l'ouest parisien journée spéciale en
direct avec toute une série d'émissions
nous reviendrons sur le programme dans
un instant est tout d'abord trois
invités nous ont rejoints pour débuter
cette journée pierre bédier bonjour
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines avec le micro gérard larcher
bonjour président du sénat bonjour et
sénateur des yvelines sénateur des
yvelines
et puis à guy pélissier également pour
jour à vous président de l'union des
maires des yvelines bonjour à vous
parler un petit peu des enjeux déjà de
ce rendez vous de cette édition 2010 9
de l'université des mairies pour vous
aujourd'hui écoutés dans un premier lieu
et dans un premier temps comme celui ci
qui devient vraiment traditionnel on est
absolument ravie de vous accueillir
toujours plus nombreux comme je disais
en confidence tout à l'heure mais vous
savez les confidences et comme les
confessions il faut les partager au
président larcher
aujourd'hui nous avons pratiquement 1000
personnes qui se sont inscrites pour
déjeuner et 1900 inscrits à cette
université 7/12 universités 12e édition
donc vous voyez ça ne vous échappera pas
nous sommes aujourd'hui en 2019 dans une
période tout à fait particulière que
vous ne connaissez pas mais vous allez
apprendre tout au long de la journée
il semble que dans cinq mois il y à des
élections à venir et qui a priori
devrait pouvoir vous intéresser voilà ce
que voulez vous dire en tout cas en
liminaire
on va préciser un commencent à organiser
ce rendez-vous l'université des mairies
sur place ya toute une série de
rencontres de débats aussi des stands
sont installés vous en verrez des images
tout à l'heure sur l'eau sur notre
antenne
un moment d'échangé le disait des
échanges qui ont lieu tous les ans avec
de nombreux participants presque presque
à un millier le programme sur notre
antenne il y aura aussi des rencontres
et des débats
il va s'afficher vous verrez tous les
rendez vous que vous pouvez suivre en
direct sur notre antenne de tv 78 et
puis ce sont des émissions bien
évidemment à revoir aussi tout au long
des prochaines semaines et puis ce
constat les
élus qui sont qui jettent de plus en
plus les pompes qui sont un peu désabusé
pierre bédier ce qu'il faut sont
inquiétés de ces mères qui jette
l'épongé a bien sûr qu'il faut s'adapter
parce que mais est ce que je peut
paraphraser le président larcher en
disant que la commune c'est la petite
république dans la grande et si les
maires arrête parce que il ya
l'agressivité considérable de nos
concitoyens parce qu'ils y allaient
difficultés financières considérables
des communes parce qu'il y a les
intercommunalités qui deviennent des
sujets de complexité croissante si cette
conjonction amène nos mères à ne pas se
représenter
c'est catastrophique pour la république
est alors dans les yvelines
j'ai changé avec pellissier on a la
chance d'avoir des maires de très grande
qualité et on le voit bien
mise à part trois quatre communes où la
situation municipale est confuse
complexe et appelle parfois des
démissions il y à une quasi unanimité
dans toutes les communes et cette
qualité là elle fait partie de la
qualité de vie dans les yvelines
quand on se promène dans les yvelines si
nos paysages sont beaux
si nos villages sont magnifiques c'est
bien parce qu'il ya eu des équipes
municipales pour permettre tout cela
donc c'est c'est vraiment à la fois
consubstantiel institutionnellement mais
aussi lié à notre qualité de vie que ce
ce potentiel départ des mères peut être
une catastrophe
gérard larcher ya une situation
contradictoire on en demande en tout cas
les administrés en demande de plus en
plus à leurs élus à leur mère à leur
équipe municipale et les pouvoirs des
maires sont de plus en plus limités il
ya aussi de cette question des
intercommunalités avec les pouvoirs qui
partent à ces communautés de communes ou
intercommunalités à ses exigences des
administrés d'abord constaté que les
maires les maires adjoints et
conseillers municipaux ce sont les élus
qui ont la confiance très majoritaire
des français
c'est d'ailleurs les seuls
et qu'à partir de la petite république
peut aider la grande république à
retrouver cette cohésion que les mères
c'est la proximité est naturellement
étant la proximité avec le sentiment que
d'autres pu voir sont plus lointains et
notamment le pouvoir national qui soit
exécutif où qu'ils soient législatif
beaucoup repose sur les épaules des
mères ce que je constate dans ce pays
parce que pour tout vous avouer samedi
j'aurai fait mon 71e réunion 71e réunion
depuis 21 mois ce sera dans le tarn et
garonne
je ne vais pas anticiper sur le tarn et
garonne mais je pourrais vous raconter
la meuse vendredi dernier c'est qu'au
fond les maires ils ont eu une année
2010 8 horribilis et horribilis parce
que entre les temps un étranglement
financier qui venait depuis cinq ans
entre le sentiment de ne plus compter de
ne plus être entendus qui a été un
moment dans la conférence nationale des
territoires ddt pensée l'exécutif pourra
retenir conférence des territoires sans
les représentants des maires des
départements et des régions
cet état c'est réussi le sentiment de la
verticalité une interco c'est vrai dont
la mise en place un peu au forceps a
donné le sentiment au maire je pense
notamment à les maires de communes moins
important de ne plus compter aux
conseillers municipaux de ne plus servir
à rien eh bien je crois que aujourd'hui
nous avons un certain nombre
d'ingrédients qui sont positifs nous
avons d'abord un débat il est en cours
il a repris il reprend ce début d'après
midi qui s'appelle l'engagement et
proximité issue d'un texte voté par le
sénat de manière transpolitique en juin
2018 qui vise à redonner au maire de la
visibilité du pouvoir à avoir une
relation avec les compétences qu'ils
soient moins systématique qu'elle soit
obligatoire ou facultative à redéfinir
la possibilité d'évoluer d'une interco à
l'autre
tout cela doit jeter les bases me
semble-t-il dans la perspective d une
nouvelle équipe municipale d'abord de
bien réaffirmer que la commune est au
coeur quel qu en soit la taille de la
république et que cette commune quelle
qu'en soit la taille est assez
symptomatique ma prochaine réunion rond
et va avoir lieu dans une commune de 80
habitants où il y aura 200 maires réunis
il ya quelque chose de symbolique à ce
que on démontre que chacune des communes
est une parcelle de la république votera
cette question pour tous les troy
aujourd'hui aussi est-ce que c'est un
phénomène nouveau mais les maires sont
inquiétés même physiquement menacés et
on arrive on aboutit quelquefois des
drames comme un signe par exemple durant
l'été avec cet élu ce maire qui a perdu
la vie en voulant s'opposer un déchet un
geste sauvages de déchets de par un
concitoyen aujourd'hui à cette menace
réelle pour les élus c'est une réalité
mais regardez sentais bien les tensions
avec les pompiers aussi l'agressivité
l'incivilité fait beaucoup plus partie
du quotidien qu'elle ne l'était il ya
dix ans la pression de certains réseaux
sociaux tout ceci contribue à une forme
de déstabilisation
moi j'étais à signes et j'ai pu mesurer
l'émotion des mères vous savez la
commission des lois du sénat a lancé une
enquête
4000 mer ont répondu et 4000 mer parmi
lesquels 92% 92% à et fait l'objet
d'agressions verbales physiques de
menaces sur eux mêmes ou leur famille
c'est pas rien qu'en 2d des choses que
nous observons dans cette enquête c'est
que et par de découragement face à 55%
les maires n'ont pas déposé plainte
aussi comprendre pourquoi c'est vrai on
vit dans une communauté qui est petit
mais aussi et je ne met personne en
cause parce que la réponse judiciaire
n'a été présente quatre places sur cinq
ont été classées sans suite
donc ceci contribue au découragement et
on peut pas d'un côté affirmé un maire
officier de police judiciaire
revêtu de l'autorité de l'état qu'il n'y
ait pas une suite
voilà pourquoi demain et après demain au
sénat nous allons débattre en quelque
sorte de l'obligation dé suivi
judiciaire d'une plainte de mer
l'effectivité il ya deux phénomènes qui
ressorte la nonne instruction quelque
sorte par les parquets d'un certain
nombre de plaintes
et puis ça concerne aussi l'autorité
préfectorale
c'est l'exécution des décisions de
justice quand elles sont prises
les maires savent bien qu'en matière
d'urbanisme et d'environnement il ya des
décisions de prises et qu'elles ne sont
suivies d'aucune exécution et que cette
exécution
je pourrais vous raconter dans
l'arrondissement de rambouillet
heureusement on est en train d'entrer
dans l'exécution de décision mais vous
voyez bien que s'il n'ya pas l'exécution
de la décision de justice aux faux plus
personne ne croit en personne ni à
l'autorité du maire ni aux dépôts de
plaintes enregistrées dans la gendarme
par la gendarmerie et la police est
ensuite plus personne ne croit
l'autorité de justice je crois qu'il
faut que la république retrouve un peu
ses marques
car bédié qui pélissier tous les deux
qu'est-ce que sans vie dans le
département aussi c'est simplement pour
dire effectivement déposé une plainte
c'est une bonne chose qu'elle soit
suivie d'effet en est une autre
le monde judiciaire à ces lenteurs à ces
règles c'est un monde particulier et que
ce soit le maire ou un citoyen lambda
qui dépose une plainte
la difficulté est la même et quel est
l'intérêt pour un maire d'aller déposer
une plainte si en réalité sa plainte
elle sera quand bien même serait tél
en tout cas succès un succès au niveau
de la poursuite elle sera jugée combien
dans deux ans trois ans après donc
l'intérêt de cette plate et
l'effectivité de la sanction et passe à
la trappe
c'est aussi à mon sens une des raisons
pour lesquelles les maires de dépose pas
plainte ou quand il la dépose ils le
font en toute illusion
en fait si vous regardez un peu c'est
quand même le maire le tissu le vrai
tissu démographique c'est quand même la
mairie et vous avez raison monsieur le
président de le dire aujourd'hui à part
les maires tous les autres caracol tous
les autres élus caracol mais en queue de
piste si on est à 78 %
les autres sont à 5 à 7% je suis ce
qu'on n'aurait pas fait rançon je suis
sûr qu'on aurait pas eu les mêmes
références
il n'en demeure pas moins que c'est le
ressens tu sais pas que le ressenti
c'est une réalité mais c'est aussi très
inquiétant c'est aussi très inquiétants
parce qu'on se sent pas relayer et on se
dit finalement si la démocratie
représentatif échoue vers quoi l'on nous
ait aussi on parlait des attentes des
concitoyens il ya des attentes aussi sur
des réalisations concrètes au sein des
communes et pour ça il faut des moyens
aujourd'hui le département vient aider
toutes les communes on pourrait citer le
département des yvelines en exemple le
département des yvelines s'efforce
naturellement après avoir lui même
traversé une période budgétaire
extrêmement critique
je rappelle à l'ensemble des élus qui
nous écoutent
nous sommes le seul département de
france dont on est quasiment supprimé la
dgf nous avons perdu 90% de notre
dotation globale de fonctionnement
imaginer dans vos mairies si vous
arrivez la disparition des 90 pensante
dgf la panique à bord alors nous avons
réussi à redresser les comptes à la fois
hélas par la fiscalité
mais c'est une fiscalité qu'en fait
l'état n'a pas le courage d'assumer
cette fiscalité la et d'autre part par
des mesures d'économie et depuis nous
sommes en situation de pouvoir aider à
nouveau les communes et massivement
puisque l'an passé ce sont
presque 100 millions d'euros et nous les
dépasserons cette année qui sont
injectés par le département le
département ils financent ses propres
politiques
c'est propre aux infrastructures mais il
finance aussi pour le compte des mères
on a créé les maires ruraux le savent
bien
ça je crois que le message est passé le
contrat rural plus puisque j'ai deux
trois courriers par jour maintenant pour
me dire est-ce que rétroactivement je
pourrais pas récupérer un peu de soul
monsieur le président je rappelle la
règle 1er janvier 2017 et autrement
redéposer un contrat rural qui sera un
contrat aura le plus donc oui nous
aidons de plus en plus fortement
financièrement mais aussi nous les
aidons à travers la structure n
générique que nous avons créée qui a été
présidée par l'ex président devenu
sénateur alain schmitt puisque il a dû
en partir c'est incompatible
ça fait partie de ces mauvaises
incompatibilité qu'on a inventé et c'est
maintenant fini mais philippe benassaya
qui est conseiller départemental qui
préside ingénierie n générés c'est une
façon aussi d'apporter aux maires des
services que l'état ne leur rapporte
plus donc c'est aussi une façon encore
une fois pour l'état de se délester de
ses charges sur les collectivités
nous essayons de bien faire dans le
département ça veut dire aujourd'hui que
l'état doit repenser aussi sans rapport
avec les élus les collectivités locales
les municipalités mais je pars cet après
midi à bourges pour le congrès des
départements en 2014 de weert le
département devait disparaître cette et
inscrit premier ministre valls avait dit
dans sa déclaration de politique
générale
imaginez la région grand est son
département
imaginez la région nouvelle aquitaine
100 départements
imaginez même la région ile-de-france
le département c'est la proximité le
département c'est un acteur de vie
sociale et cohésion territoriale
la vraie réponse c'est pas d'opposer
l'état aux départements et aux régions
je crois que nous avons besoin d'une
nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation savez notre système de
santé
et centralisée j'ai moi même été
président de la fédération des hôpitaux
publics en matière de centralité je me
connais mais est ce qu'on peut continuer
dans l'état dans lequel vous sentez
notre santé des réponses sur le
territoire à avoir des politiques qui
sont totalement centralisée dans ce
domaine là demain nous allons voir le
président de conseil départemental de
saône et loire qui n'est pas j'allais
dire un révolutionnaire avancé pour
trouver les médecins dette
il est obligé d'en salariés et l'année
prochaine il aura 100 médecins salariés
en saône-et-loire sinon ya plus de
médecins en saône et loire
il ya père capita trois fois moins de
médecins qu'il y en a dans les yvelines
par nombre d'habitants et donc vous
voyez bien que la proximité la réponse
des départements comme la réponse des
régions dans le domaine économique ou
dans le domaine de l'emploi
c'est demain une nouvelle génération de
la décentralisation et un état
territorial renforcée nous avons besoin
de préfecture avec des services for nous
avons besoin de sous préfecture nous
avons besoin que les préfectures sur les
patrons et non pas des agents six
nominés dont les directeurs et nominé
décide de l'attribution de dotation au
logement ou des décisions à caractère
environnemental
en fait on a besoin d'un état
territorial fort comme nous avons besoin
de départements de communes et de région
qui soit forte
je crois que sinon se redressera pas et
que la cohésion qui est indispensable au
pays ont leur construire a ainsi permis
d'y et la transition est presque trouvé
toute trouvée on parlait des
départements de l'importance des
départements forcément je pose cette
question parce qu'il ya encore quelques
jours ou quelques semaines dans la
presse et quelques fuites plus ou moins
démenti sur un rapprochement entre les
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine qui
serait plus ou moins officialisé
aujourd'hui concrètement au nom des eaux
alors ce qui a été décidé par le
président de la république ça n'est pas
la fusion de nos deux départements
c'est la mise à l'étude de cette fusion
le ministre le corps nu et donc chargé
officiellement par le président de la
république d'y réfléchir
et aucune décision n'est encore prise et
aucune décision ne sera prise le
ministre me l'a dit avant les élections
municipales
la fenêtre de tir soir au lendemain des
élections municipales et elle appellera
de toute façon une position claire sur
l'organisation de la région parisienne
c'est aussi ça l'objectif de la fusion
est ce que nous voulons la métropole le
rikiki c'est à dire le partage de la
richesse entre paris et les trois
départements de petite couronne où est
ce que nous considérons que la métropole
doit être construite à l'échelle de la
région
nous sommes le seul territoire de france
où la métropole et inter départementale
lyon c'est le département du rhône
lille c'est le département du nord
nantes c'est le département de la loire
atlantique et c'est donc nous sommes les
seuls dans ce cas de figure
et cette construction de la fusion c'est
une façon de créer la dynamique
haussière l'ouest parisien
car nous sommes les grands oubliés des
contrats de plan alors les élus le
savent mieux que personne
depuis 40 ans au nom du rééquilibrage à
l'est ce qu on fait du déséquilibre âge
à l'ouest alors laissons l'ouest
s'organiser pour pouvoir être en
dynamique d'infrastructures et en
dynamique économique arrive bientôt à la
fin nous avons bientôt à la fin de cette
première émission consacrée à
l'université des mairies un dernier tour
de table ont parlé des élections
municipales qui sont un enjeu pour les
prochains mois aujourd'hui ces élus qui
hésitent à se relancer ou ses citoyen
qui hésitent à s'engager en politique
vous leur dites quoi les uns et les
autres à écouter de toute façon je pense
pas qu'il y est des missions des merles
emerse hommes ou femmes sont des gens
volontaires qui m
c'est qu'ils aiment ce qu'ils font c'est
un véritable sacerdoce
je crois qu'on peut compter sur mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même une
certaine désaffection
il ya un an on n'a jamais vu en réalité
tant de personnes après un seul mandat
vouloir cesser ses activités pour
simplement une bonne raison ils n'ont
plus de moyens financiers on ne parlera
tout à l'heure ils ont des attributions
encore moindre
et puis il ya toujours ce millefeuille
administratif qui apporte un petit peu
de tempérament à l'ardeur de mes deux
colistiers ne s'est pas des colistiers
on n'est pas colistiers m'enfin on est
tourné sur le même plateau et ce
millefeuille administratif un moment ou
un autre il faudra quand même bien y
réfléchir le simplifier et par
définition il y aura des suppressions
qu'on le veuille ou pas
alors moi je dis en réalité si vous
voulez que les mères continuent
réellement et croire réellement la
politique m'a fait en sorte
effectivement que ce millefeuille soit
manifestement simplifiée et simplifiée
ça sera une bonne chose pour les
finances locales le mandat 2014 2020
était un mandat très difficile pour les
mères et j'avais dit à mon successeur
moi j'ai connu l'âge d'or tu vas
connaître l'âge de pierre baisse des
dotations intercommunalités forcé
abondance de normes
c'est vraiment six années extrêmement
difficiles mais six années où les mères
aux tenues parce que je voudrais quand
même rappeler dans l'état où était notre
pays en descendre 2018
on est passé pas très loin de la bascule
s'il n'y avait pas eu les maires de
france quelle que soit leur sensibilité
compte tenu le coup qu'on était les
arcs-boutants de la république et donc
leur mandat il est essentiel il est
essentiel qu'elle que soit la commune et
quelle que soit la partie du territoire
est donc ce que nous essayons bâtir
aujourd'hui compris au parlement et
particulièrement au sénat c'est les
perspectives plus clair pour 2020 est de
bâtir au cours de l'année 2020 avec bien
sûr le bloc communal les départements
les régions non pas dans un conflit avec
l'état
cette nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation si on n'en passe pas
par là je ne vois pas comment notre pays
pourra se redresser pas simplement et
économiquement et j'allais dire presque
moralement car regarder le tableau
sentait bien que ça craque d'un peu
partout et que le premier déçu j'essaie
de retrouver la cohésion faire
communauté nationale au singulier
toutes ces choses là me paraissent
tellement essentiel est à la base de
tout ça ira comme une comédie un dernier
mot autour de ce sujet
moi je suis très très inquiet de
l'augmentation continuelle des normes
qui évoquait gérard larcher parce que je
pense que c'est elle qui est en train de
tuer la démocratie et je vais en prendre
un exemple que tous les maires dont on
comprend lorsque vous décidez en début
de mandat de réaliser un équipement
comme vous mettez plus de six ans vous
tapez tous les emmerdements qui vont
vous amener éventuellement être battu
alors que vous n'aurez pas le plaisir de
pouvoir inaugurer cet équipement et
c'est extrêmement dangereux pour la
démocratie
le plus beau des exemples c'est l'eau et
l'assainissement
on a changé cinq fois de règles de
dotation d'attribution aux six ans sur
un même dossier
on a vu ce empiler des normes qui
changent et on a fait les études dvd
contre-étude d'airé étude est arrivé
d'en haut une décision ou le triton
rares réapparaissez pardonnez moi la vie
quotidienne ça veut dire aujourd'hui
qu'il faut faire confiance aux élus du
territoire dans une relation avec l'état
territorial incarné par le corps
préfectoral
c'est ça la réalité je partage sur les
normes voilà pourquoi nous n'hésitons
pas à dire qu'il faudra un ensemble
normative dont certains soient données
aux territoires et non plus décidé d'en
haut voudrais simplement vous dire pour
une rencontre récente avec les élus
d'outre-mer
savez-vous qu'on a les mêmes normes à
saint martin et à saint barth que nous
pouvons avoir
dans les yvelines où dans le pas de
calais vous voyez bien que ça pourra pas
durer éternellement comme ça vous voyez
bien les échangeurs pourrait encore se
poursuivre longtemps sur ce plateau en
tout cas ils vont se poursuivre ici à
port marly pour cette nouvelle édition
2010 9 de l'université et des mairies et
rendez vous des collectivités locales de
l'ouest parisien
nous faisons une petite pause sur
l'antenne de tv 78 et les mises
émissions vont reprendre avec un débat
consacré au logement social avec de
nouveaux invités merci à vous monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]